[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West pack on
the PDA in a rare intimate photo the
mama for took to Instagram on Sunday
with this black and white pic of the
couple sharing a sweet embrace and
smooch and love that soda
khloe kardashian who commented on her
sisters post quote
long live Kim yang both Kim and Kanye
are dressed down in the snap and based
on the scenery it looks like they might
be in Wyoming a state they've been
spending lots of time in lately I just
love your outfits I got you from Wyoming
yeah
but while the Kardashian West's fam
might have a thing for the wild wild
west Kim told et earlier this month she
has no plans of relocating full-time
nothing out west to wear oh maybe he
just purchased a house so yeah is that
something like you could be packetized
moving out there entirely well I heard
the winters are intense so I am going to
have my husband feel that out for me to
see if he can survive the fashions also
know where do I go to all these vintage
stores I took my best friend Allison
last weekend we were going to like the
Boot Barn we're going all around these
places I love it there but I'm from LA
so I think I'll always be grounded in LA
but I love it there and I definitely
won't be spending time there
meanwhile the reality fans spent Friday
night in Detroit for Kanye's debut of
his first gospel LP if Jesus is king
during as Jesus's King a Kanye West
experience event at the city's Fox
Theater it's amazing it's really the
sound is just so like I can't even
explain the sound it's really like
healing
[Music]
you